die nasa steht gerade vor einem riesigen
reizende konkret geht es um äußerst
mysteriöse objekte die der kolosse
tiroler auf der marsoberfläche
aufgespürt hat eines von ihnen glänzt
ungewöhnlich stark und sieht ein wenig
aus wie ein kleines gold nugget weltweit
wird gerätselt was das für teile sein
könnten etwa müll von aliens oder
handelt es sich um überreste von
meteoriten die nasa selbst ist dem
rätsel jedenfalls mit intensiver
forschung auf der spur alles was zu dem
mysteriösen fund auf dem mars zu wissen
ist dass er war der sieg zum science
fiction nur hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen klar ist derzeit
steht er die nasa-sonde inside im
rampenlicht gerade erst auf dem mars
gelandet sendet sie immer neue bilder
vom roten planeten zu uns auf die erde
doch mindestens genauso spannend ist der
aktuelle fund des skoda citigo was der
schon seit 2012 bilder vom mars schick
denn fast zeitgleich mit der insight
landung hat er eine entdeckung gemacht
die forschungsteams weltweit staunen
lässt auf der karosse die aufnahme sieht
eines der objekte aus wie ein langer
stein mit einer extrem glänzenden
oberfläche
die nasa selbst hat dessen formen wohl
an eine kleine insel namens call on sea
nördlich von schottland erinnert daher
der name little colón fest stehe
jedenfalls niemand kann dieses objekt
derzeit sicher zuordnen worum handelt es
sich genau und woher stammt es im netz
werden gerade wilde spekulationen
aufgestellt handelt es sich vielleicht
sogar um alien müll gibt es also endlich
ein beweis für außerirdisches leben
die experten und expertinnen der nasa
dagegen vermuten dass es sich um teile
eines meteoriten handeln könnte
das legt die oberfläche des mysteriösen
objekts nahe doch in einem nasa bericht
steht auch das aussehen kann täuschen
zunächst ist eine chemische analyse
erforderlich um seine beschaffenheit zu
erforschen und beweise zu erhalten nun
stehen also einige untersuchungen an um
das objekt ein für alle mal eindeutig zu
identifizieren dazu wird eine so
genannte camp genutzt also chemische
kamera hierbei wird ein laserstrahl auf
dass rentner objekt gefeuert wodurch
material verdampft das dann genauer
analysiert werden kann
das alles soll durch eine kamera des
mars rovers aufgezeichnet
ein erster analyse versuch war zunächst
gescheitert und das mysteriöse objekt
wurde verfehlt doch die nasa gibt die
hoffnung nicht auf schließlich wurde
eine solche analyse bereits im jahr 2006
an einem anderen zunächst nicht
identifizierbaren objekt erfolgreich
durchgeführt damals ließ sich so
ermitteln dass dieses teil aus einer
nickel eisen gemisch bestand und es sich
somit um einen meteoriten gehandelt
hatte übrigens ist das gold nugget
ähnliche objekt aktuell nicht das
einzige teil auf dem mars das der nasa
kopfzerbrechen bereitet drei weitere
teile müssten chemische noch genauer
untersucht werden um eindeutig bestimmt
zu werden unter anderem ein sehr
winziges objekt mit einer dunklen
beschichtung dass die nasa flanders moss
getauft hat das es ebenfalls ein name
aus schottland flanders moss ist nämlich
ein hochmoor gebiet nördlich von glasgow
es bleibt also in jedem fall spannend
und es gibt noch eine menge auf dem
markt zu entdecken wenn es neuigkeiten
dazu gibt dann erfahrt ihr natürlich
zuerst und als allererste wenn er
unseren whatsapp newsletter hier
draufklicken abonniert und dann runter
geht es weiter mit der oder da drüber
oder hier also hier geht irgendwo weiter
mit mars wurm leben auf dem mars
gefunden
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran